(en russe)
- Les voeux par téléphone de
Vladimir Poutine à une famille
russe pour le Noël orthodoxe.
L'occasion aussi pour
le président russe de décréter
un cessez-le-feu général en
Ukraine, le premier depuis
l'invasion, à la demande des
autorités religieuses de Russie
et du président turc, Erdogan.
À compter de midi demain
jusqu'à minuit le lendemain,
les armes russes se tairont tout
le long de la ligne de front,
invitant les forces ukrainiennes
à respecter elles aussi
cette trêve de 36 heures.
Un répit bienvenu pour l'armée
russe, en mauvaise posture
depuis des mois, encore
sonnée par le bombardement de
sa caserne à Makiivka, le jour
de l'An, qui a fait au moins
89 morts chez des mobilisés
et beaucoup de blessés.
Mais cette annonce d'une trêve
est reçue avec beaucoup de
scepticisme côté ukrainien.
"Ils vont peut-être arrêter
de tirer pour une journée, mais
quelle différence cela va faire,
dit ce soldat. C'est absurde
et cynique."
À Kiev, le président Zelensky
a affirmé quant à lui que
la guerre ne finira que lorsque
les soldats russes quitteront
son pays.
"Ils veulent simplement
profiter de Noël pour renforcer
leurs positions", accuse-t-il.
À Washington, le président
Biden doute aussi de la
sincérité de Vladimir Poutine.
"C'est intéressant, dit-il,
parce que le 25 décembre et
le jour de l'An, ils n'hésitent
pas à bombarder des hôpitaux et
des églises", estimant aussi que
les Russes veulent simplement
se donner le temps de respirer.
Washington a du même souffle
confirmé l'envoi en Ukraine
de blindés légers, un cadeau
de Noël bienvenu, d'autant plus
qu'ils s'ajoutent à des dons
équivalents de la France
et de l'Allemagne.
À Kiev en tout cas, beaucoup
ont déjà choisi de s'aligner
désormais sur le calendrier
grégorien en fêtant Noël
le 25 décembre.
Comme Oleksandra, qui dit ne
plus vouloir célébrer Noël
le 7 janvier en même temps
que les Russes, un Noël qui,
à ses yeux, n'a rien de saint.
Ici Jean-François Bélanger,
Radio-Canada, Montréa